alors c'est vrai que tu sécher d'école
pour les chanter dans les bals oui oui
je chantais dans la banlieue-est doigts
vincennes le genre c'est quoi la raw
dire et ton père chantait des chansons
19 cents déjà non ah oui la maison bon
père il chantait tout le temps c'était
que c'est une chose qui se perd un peu
dur c'est peut-être que les chansons
sont moins chantable enfin je veux dire
c'est trop facile de chanter du rap
messieurs c'est quoi ton père par
exemple à chanter c'est la chanson des
peupliers la fille
et
celle d'abou mazen des doigts
la caravane
bakou
d'abord quel paquet cependant l'âge
qu'il a repris ce costume violet ce que
je faisais alors tu venais comme une
chanson d'abonnés haut débit lié à ben
et or l'année dernière des enfants ont
poussé à faire un disque une idée à ou
devrait vraiment une idée house et la
version officielle c'est encore oui non
non non c c c'est xavier qui adore le
musée du mali mais tu devrais ouais tu
veux rire car ça alors j'ai essuyé des
refus poli de deux producteurs tu
prenable pour un dingue jusqu'à temps
que je rencontre paul lederman chez lui
a dit mais oui tout à fait et bon ben
voilà ils feront combien se le dise
lederman à jean zay n'en sais rien le
producteur non sa balle de l'afrique et
je vous promets et d'argent bon bon y'a
quoi sur ce disque elle raconte nous un
petit peu parce que ça il faut dire ça
se montrait très très bien vous êtes à
combien 200 milles ouais y'a quoi sur ce
disque eh ben il ya d'abord un pot
pourri de java un impôt pourri de vals
et il ya et puis d'aider des grands
standards du musette détruit des années
30 à 50 ans tu sais que tu vas pas y
couper
oui oui vous bien moi j'en ai préparé
quelques-unes que j'ai envie de son
temps mais brad et moi j'aime bien le
petit cabanon d'allibert à l'évasion
petit cabanon aussi pas plus grand qu'un
mouchoir de poche un petit cabanon robot
de la mûre sur les roches pour vivre qui
fait bon quand l'alcool à gaza doigts
croches sommes pavillon joyeux qui
claquent dans notre ciel bleu à
l'intérieur une table et c'est tout il
met sur 7 à table il y faudra surtout un
aïoli odorant et cordial dont se
régalera le gourmand provençal c'est
pourquoi s'en passe en jeu
10la dans ma cave gauche loeb on l'a
tellement bon je te tout petit cabanon
et devrait ravir les cieux cette
émission cette émission c'est ta de
kallstrom mardi et ça s'est passé un
dimanche à nantes est pas sorti de
l'auberge avec moi avons d'accord ouais
elle avait tout pour lui plaire
il avait tout faux lui plaire aussi mais
c'est la vie tu es à bécon les bruyères
et lui devant est à bercy il fallut que
le dieu de l'amour
les filles seront contrés cette
rencontre ait lieu à un beau jour
devrait vous la racontez pas encore prêt
pour ça s'est passé un dimanche
un dimanche au bord de lure elle avait
sa robe blanche lui sont hyper moqueur à
carreaux il avait également des petits
dieux rigolo une langue qui était
pendant sa manche
alors ils invitent à la jolie de kilos à
se cacher du soleil sous les branches
ça s'est passé un dimanche à dimanche au
bord de l'eau c'est tout
j'avais à l'époque dont les musiques
sont ce qu'elles sont elles vont changer
devant évoluer mais y avait il ya aussi
des paroliers formidable effet des
mélodies well et des bonnes paroles
jean souvient les témoins non bah oui je
crois que j'ai une bonne mémoire oui oui
mais il y avait par exemple jean boyer a
écrit il et des trucs qui sont
formidables et qui marque toute une
époque par exemple celui qui avait écrit
pour au moins au moment de la guerre de
39 il a écrit au maurice chevalier et
tout ça ça fait d'excellents français
l'excellent c'est marrant j'ai commencé
c'est gai c'est un peu cocorico c'est
vrai mais dans le fond pourquoi pas
l'être c'est pas si mal d'être français
donc